in the midst of some of the worst civil
unrest that we've seen in this country
for a long time coming at the juncture
of a hundred year pandemic police
killings of black men that have
generated massive protests a huge
economic recession Donald Trump is now
bragging he has been the best president
for black people since Abraham Lincoln
Trump tweeting this week quote my
administration has done more for the
black community than any president since
Abraham Lincoln passed Opportunity Zones
which with senator Tim Scott guaranteed
funding for HBCUs school choice past
criminal justice reform lowest black
unemployment poverty and crime rates in
history and then adding in a second
tweet in all caps and the best is yet to
come so let's pretend that this is
serious and this is a serious person
making a serious claim the first
question is does this even pass the
sniff test does it pass the test that
tump Trump has done more for the black
community than any president dating all
the way back to Abraham Lincoln it
doesn't sound right and obviously it's
not right and Trump's persistent dog
whistles to white nationalists are only
a tiny tiny piece of it but let's pick
one of those things and actually think
about it in a little bit more detail so
one of the claims that Trump regularly
made before 25% of the workforce lost
their jobs because the coronavirus was
that black unemployment is at record
lows and that Trump is of course to
thank for that
a couple things what you need to
understand is that when unemployment is
very low it's typically low for every
group so we no doubt had a very low
unemployment rate up until the corona
virus pandemic started when we talked
about the economy leading up to the
pandemic I made no effort to deceive or
hide the fact that we had a low
unemployment rate it was very low for
white people it was low for black people
it was you know low for young and old
people it was low for men and women it
was low for college graduates and non
college graduates so
thinking back to my interview earlier
this week with Jonathan Faber about
critical thinking was black unemployment
low because of something Trump did was
black unemployment low and it applied to
all groups because of something Trump
did or was this part of the sort of
natural cycle of the economy what we
know is job growth certainly slowed from
the pace under Barack Obama but again
only some of this has to do with the
president so the logical question to ask
would be what specifically did Donald
Trump do that disproportionately created
jobs for black Americans relative to non
black Americans and when you actually
boil it down and think about it in this
way Trump didn't do anything
there was nothing now I'm gonna give you
one other example of this remember
during Barack Obama's presidency the
right would regularly say a record
number of people aren't working a record
number of people are outside of the
labor force and then Trump is
inaugurated and instantly up until three
months ago some of those same people
were saying a record number of people
are working now and it didn't sound
right how is it that we went from record
numbers of people not working under
Obama to record numbers of people
working under Donald Trump doesn't
really make sense well the truth is
during Obama's presidency a record
number of people were working and a
record number of people were not working
likewise during Trump's presidency
before coronavirus of course a record
number of people were working and a
record number of people were not working
how is this possible the answer is the
population keeps growing if at any given
time roughly 55 percent of the
population is in the workforce and 45
percent of the population is out of the
workforce as long as our population
keeps growing
you will simultaneously continue to have
more people working than ever before and
more people not working than ever before
the devil is in the details why are
people not working is it because they
don't have to because the economy's
doing really well is it because there
are no
jobs is it because there's been a
population shift to more older folks who
are retirement age or a population shift
to a lot of more college aged people who
when they are not working even if you're
in college full time you count as being
out of the labor force how much are
people earning are their wages allowing
them to afford the cost of living
wherever it is that they live so as you
can very quickly see for a long time
we've had a record number of people
working and a record number of people
not working coronavirus of course has
changed that but the question is is
Trump doing more for black people than
anyone since Abraham Lincoln that is
obviously untrue and it's something that
only a pathological pathological liar or
completely delusional person would say
they live for the sake of lying
they are hyperbolic in their lies and
that's all that this is and let's not be
confused about it